[Music]
good morning bachelor nation thank you
for being here with et for roses and
roses a live I have none other then team
corn here round of applause for Koran in
with studio
you brought a high pony to play today I
love this yeah flip it around and tell
me how you're feeling about this season
of The Bachelor I'd give me one word no
you guys I knew she would have her hot
takes I'm so excited that Kareem is here
to talk about Rebecca Cooper in season
of The Bachelorette and of course last
night we had hometowns hometowns
happened we had the final four now it's
the final three sports are not my thing
but the Bachelorette is and I want to
know what you thought of last night's
episode and of course your questions for
Korean cuz we're gonna catch up with all
that's going on with her as well send
them to us we will get your comments
here on the iPad and I will ask them of
Miss Quran so your word is know your
word is know a little bit about why oh I
just personally I just haven't really
been able to like get so into it I don't
know I just I think she's great she's a
lovely human like wow I'm amazing inside
and out I'm just not into the season
okay fare well last night was hometowns
I've been up and down on it I think it's
picked up in the past couple episodes
and first we started off with Garrett's
I want to talk to you about Garrett
Garrett's the want to have the Instagram
scandal no yeah what did you think of
his apology especially someone you know
being so active and wonderful on social
media like you are um I mean you just
got to be smart enough that if you're
gonna be in the public eye and you're
gonna you know that like social media is
life right now don't do stuff like that
yeah unless you like don't care which I
mean if someone does something that
dramatic like clearly you don't care so
phony apology okay so you did not
believe it you were not into his apology
another no from Quran okay well we're
gonna see we will talk to Garrett
eventually you know when this all winds
down I'm so Garrett and Becka
when
to his home that planted some plants on
his farm what did you think of that
hometown visit like I don't know he
brought her up on the tractor and he was
telling her could you see yourself out
here the tractor like what I'm so
ridiculous I just think it's weird
because I think in that moment you know
I don't know especially if you're doing
something you've never done before maybe
you're like sure this is fun but I think
I would have said no I'm not gonna be
out here on the tractor planting the
things but that's just me maybe Becca's
really into it okay then Garrett we also
met his family and his mom was very
intense she said she is a mother bear
she said that she was gonna go
no-holds-barred
I loved her what did you think of his
family great great great family yeah
they were not messing around and Garrett
has really opened up about having been
divorced a half married once before I
wanted to get your take especially being
you know of course a contestant on the
show how much are you encouraged to talk
about your family like were you hesitant
to bring up any family drama these guys
have really divulged like really giving
me in front of their families I feel
like you just feel like you have to
meeting someone trying to get engaged to
someone in such a quick amount of time
such a short amount of time I'm sorry um
you just feel like you have to get it
all out there because if something's not
going to work you want to know now that
make sense yeah
so from Garrett we are going to move on
to Jason because she went to Jason next
in New York and Jason I like but I don't
know I she keeps saying he's a great
kisser but I'm just not sure I don't
feel a connection and tell me why I
don't know I just when I watch them I
just don't feel sparks or magic or like
wow they're really into each other and I
felt like their date was a little bit
awkward he keeps getting thrown into
like bar and restaurant situations he
was on his one-on-one you went on like a
happy hour then they were eating wings
it wasn't very I don't know I didn't
love it as television what do you think
of Jason's hair because I always loved
your take on um well last night I was
watching and I like blurted out that he
looked like he just got out of a fryer
but
it's yeah I'm slickness to it it's too
much it's a dated look if I'm being
honest Jason I think he's a good-looking
guy and I think he's really funny I'm
not into it he reminds me a little bit
of Kermit the Frog Oh interesting yeah
he always reminds me of a different
movie like he's very much a character to
me with that hair and it's very it's
very like 80s New York I feel like I
could see him on Wall Street with his
look I'm ready feel like he looks like
he should be smoking a cigar going like
hello Punk so Jason we like but I don't
know if I'm seeing no they're not gonna
end up together
you don't think so I don't think so what
was strange to me and watching this
whole hometown episode I want to know
what you guys think so tell me if he
felt the same is that last week Becca
said to not to Blake but on camera that
she's in love with Blake so it's very
strange to watch her interactions with
these other guys and to feel like they
feel really solid and real when we know
that in the back of her head she's in
love with Blake mm-hmm it's a whole lot
of emotions when you're is it confusing
thrown into there yeah it's very
confusing it's really stressful and I
don't I don't blame her for feeling
feelings but still trying to feel
feelings to other people I like that you
feel the feelings but you're still
trying to fill the other annual feelings
because why should she keep trying like
is it because she still needs to explore
like how do ya you still need to explore
like great you started feeling feelings
for someone but you want to see if
there's anything else they're still fine
if there really isn't and she knows
there isn't then send them home okay
even if you just go from straight to
forward to to you know well we will see
or she sent home we also had Blake I
like Blake tell me Lake had the shooting
at the school that was so real and so
sad and talked about that that was it
gave me such tells a good family friend
of mine was actually involved in the
shooting in parkland Florida it was her
school but she was actually sick that
day but a few of her friends got really
injured and it's just been a really
dramatic time so I really that hit close
to home for me so that's I love his
positivity well and I love that the show
did go in a route of like leaving that
conversation in because sometimes I feel
like we've gotten hints but
or that you know again they're making a
TV show but I remember re saying well
Becca and I did talk about potli he told
Becca Stanley we talked about politics
and religion I thought but we never saw
those conversations you don't see a lot
of stuff mean Nick had so many real
relationship conversations that were
never shown they just showed me like
jumping on him in a bounce house or
being ridiculous you know they didn't
show like my actual really deep combos
that I had with Nick so I get it was
that frustrating
okay comments coming in Cecile wants to
know and okay let's dive right into
Colton's a--rewin talk about Colton yes
she wants to know do you think that
Colton was sent home because Tia told
Ben about her feelings for him I
honestly am bothered by that whole
situation I don't even see why Tia felt
the need to tell her that she had
feelings for him cuz what does it matter
she has nothing to do with anything
Becka is the Bachelorette and Colton is
one of her guys why would Becca care if
Tia had feelings for him it would be
different if Colton had gone to Becca
and said hey I have feelings for Tia I'm
gonna leave and go try to find Tia but
for Tia to just come on her season be
like I have feelings for Colton
and okay well and I think Becca Shannon
said that she was frustrated because
she'd sort of given t of that chance
earlier in the season she'd seemed to
come in now and try to do that come on
come on are you like really thirsty or
what I'm over it it really pisses me off
actually I think that's really rude and
I think it's really disrespectful and I
think that it was way out of line and
that should not have been allowed so do
you think when you say thirsty do you
mean that Tia way come on you just like
you just want him now because Becca's
going far with him okay
like once what she can't have it's what
you think kind of do you think it was
like thirsty that she was just wanting
Colton or thirsty like she wanted a
moment to be back on TV I mean we're all
oh he's gonna be on TV one way or
another so I don't think it was that I
think it was more just like come on like
you just now you want him like
interesting no well we do know it was
revealed last night after Colton was
sent home that Colton goes to Paradise
obviously
you know Tia was in paradise so
obviously they went on a date there's
already been photos leaked of them
indeed and great they're gonna wind up
together and have babies and he's a
virgin and whatever okay but you don't
believe that I don't cuz he already lied
about so many other things interesting
Dyer so I've thought about this and tell
me what you think my deal is I think if
he really wasn't a virgin wouldn't a
woman have come forward at this point
like gone to a blog said something like
yeah that and I thought about that but
there has to be one way or another like
a drunken night no one knows names this
that I feel like it happened you do I do
so you're calling Colt now you think
Colton is lying I'm callin B yes okay
interesting I mean it was unique to
watch his discussions with his family
during his home town last night because
like becos talking his mom and his mom
was like yeah she he kind of just told
me that I was his mom saying that he
just told her that he's a virgin like it
was so wild and the whole thing just
makes me honestly really uncomfortable
well if we want to talk about a moment
if we can bring up guys the moment that
Colton had with Chris Harrison why let's
play this sound and relive it here is
cold and asking Chris Harrison for
advice about fantasy suites which are
about to happen next week yes I just
want to know sort of what the
expectations are are you saying you are
worried about being intimate with Becca
at this point yeah yeah
the main thing is as long as you have
Becca are on the same page and happen
that's all that matters yeah how you
choose to handle that as a man as a
couple how Becca choose handle it that's
up to you that's thought that's kind of
the whole point of it Chris Harrison's
eyes in that moment he was like okay
just very awkward and bizarre thing to
bring up randomly like okay what does
Chris Harrison gonna do such a good
question I'm like of all I don't know
maybe he felt like who else could he
talk to me now no age too what do you
think no there's so many people there
that you can talk to believe me so why
did he go to Chris Harrison
I think he just wanted to have like a
moment interesting what do you think of
all this charity work we saw it last
night on beautiful yes beautiful
beautiful beautiful honestly st.
work I think that it'll be interesting
to hear more from Colton and I want to
make it clear totally cold his thing
that he's a virgin have no problem with
it it was just we had some fun funny
interesting moments last night to
watches all of that played out
especially when he said that his daddy's
relationship with his dad was like a
coach I was like that is interesting
there's so much to dig into so much
baggage yes Diane from YouTube's of
Kareem you are so naturally beautiful
love you with your hair pulled back Asia
from YouTube is disagreeing with us she
likes Jason's hair well it's an
old-school look for sure
it's an acquired taste ladies might be
into or not I like Jason I think he's
funny Jenny says Blake for bachelor he's
such a cutie who is your call for
bachelor and I mean without if you know
anything let's not reveal I don't know
anything I do you think like no good
bachelor yeah I do yeah I you know what
because he's already again like sharing
so much and I think is the lead you have
to share so much
I saw you also said recently that you
felt like you should have been the
Bachelorette which I would have loved to
watch tell me would you be a bachelor
right now I think America would have
loved to watch that because y'all know I
just said y'all y'all know I'm gonna be
real I'm gonna be whatever but honestly
everything happens for a reason reason
reason I have an amazing boyfriend and
I'm so happy if you were single in the
future would you do Bachelorette in the
future I really hope I'm never gonna be
single in the future but yes I would of
course I love my bachelor family I love
my bachelor nation I love my little
batch ease of course so the thing is but
it's I know you and Rachel are tight but
when you're like why should have been
the Bachelorette it was Rachel instead
like I don't know is that but is that no
I'm not saying that I should have been
instead of anyone I should just be one
Rachel killed it
I'm a girl she really did kill it but I
know that you have said that you feel
like the past couple seasons we're
pretty damn I mean tell me what you
think the issue is I just shut it down
yeah I really just shut it down I set
the bar too high for y'all
I'm kidding I'm kidding no um I don't
know I mean I just feel like the show is
changing everything changing it's a
different era and we got it we got to
get back in the groove got to find our
niche again is it nature neat I think
it's preference okay but you know what
commenters let us know what you do when
you say that III think you're right in
that I'm ready for like something new to
be tried I mean what do you mean by get
back in the groove tell me what you
think I mean it used to be like so
special so emotional now it's like
alright who's gonna be this character
who's gonna be this character how many
followers are you gonna get what can you
sponsor like you know and it used to
never be about any of that
mm-hmm yeah the I think Instagram has
changed people's reach oh my god it
changed everything yeah it's kind of
wild right D can you think of any way
they could combat that like in older
people
late 20s late 20s early 30s I think that
it needs to be an older crowd I don't
think that there should be 22 23 year
olds on it anymore I think that it
should be people who are really there to
find love looking back do you feel like
you were at a good age to go on it like
what is the age you're saying yeah well
if I were to tell my sister to go on it
I'd say you're not going on it unless
you're 25 or older okay
so Roman mid-20s I was 24 I feel like I
was right there but I know it's a tough
call it's a tough call well I'm with you
because you know originally the premise
of the show was really kind of bringing
in people who'd had a hard time finding
love and whatnot 22 23 it's like you
know yeah I haven't even had a minute
yet you just out of college I just broke
up a night babe I'm in it for that
struggle yes so many comments coming in
for you another one on YouTube this
person says I like Garrett and I don't
like Garrett my feelings are complicated
okay I am right there with you honey Oh
tell me why I just really don't like
like you got to be smarter like like and
I believe that he is smarter and I
believe that he knew what he was doing
writing those comments and I believed
that he believed
in what he wrote mm-hmm so now he's just
backtracking is that how you felt yeah I
feel like he is not down for the
aftermath all right well we're gonna
have to see we're going to have to see
Mandy says Korean who do you think Beca
should pick then I think Becca should
pick Blake my Blake is just he's
wonderful I love Blake every but if she
doesn't pick him next Bachelor
hell yes we are here for Blake
so of course Colton was sent home and I
wasn't surprised by this I mean I think
that Becca was very attracted to Colton
do you think that it was I was surprised
you were tell me why I was surprised
because if Becca really wasn't feeling
it right when Tia told her that even
though I think Tia was totally wrong to
do that
Becca should have just been like you
know what he's not really there for me
yet anyway and I'm really happy you told
me that and I want to tell you that he's
not there for me yet mmm you know I mean
she made it as if like no like I love
him like what like Wyatt but yeah I
don't know I was really surprised and
then I thought she was just gonna keep
him there out of spite
so I was like he's not going home
interesting yeah well colon was sent
home and we have got the final three now
and yeah I'm with you I love Blake it
looks like I both want back at a pic
Blake and I think like I think pylon two
is Blake and Garrett bum bum bum it was
kind of crazy to hear like Jason say
that he's in love like all these guys I
feel have fallen really hard for her
they're all like yeah here we got the
bachelor in paradise promo last night
and I wanted to talk to you about
Paradise returning it's just kind of
crazy like that all the scandal stuff
was a year ago
does that go strange T it really does
honestly like people don't realize what
I actually went through going through
something like that and it's whole
bizarre but it's also so refreshing that
it's a year ago when we're starting a
new chapter and it's been out
really wild here and and people don't
realize all the struggles I really have
gone through so you know with me like
picking myself back up throwing myself
back into work I am a businesswoman I
believe me a lot of business disappeared
from that and its really it was really
hard for me because it wasn't my fault
it wasn't me that said something I never
said a bad word about anyone made a
complaint this that you know so hard
year was it the hardest year of your
life it was it really was I think was
the hardest year of my life and my
family's life so when you look back one
of the hardest for my family
aside my mom going through cancer and
things like that obviously but you do
have to deal with so much scrutiny it
was bad yeah when you're saying people
don't realize what you went through what
would you want to tell those people so
that they understand what you did go
through better it's heartbreaking it's
heartbreaking and a lot of people don't
realize how intense it is being in that
situation like I didn't want to leave my
house I didn't want to eat I didn't want
to talk to anyone I probably looked at
my phone maybe like half a second
everyday maybe like half a second I know
I throw it and just not even like care
about it I didn't want to leave I didn't
want to eat I didn't want to do anything
I was just like oh let this be over
because it was just and it feels
never-ending I've literally felt at the
time like this is never gonna go away
when you were shutting yourself out from
the world like that was it because it
was just too hard to process at all I
think I just really needed to go under
the radar you know less is more in in
situations like that and I needed to
heal my own self yeah it was a healing
process I remember Demario saying to
like he lost weight during it oh my god
we were both a mess hot mess so looking
back a year later what do you feel like
you learned from everything I went
through
how would have my self I am a strong
woman and I hope that other women can
you know feel strong in situations where
they feel weak and you know bring
themselves back up and and show the
world that they're strong and make a
comeback and that nothing can get you
down for good do you think you were
longer even than you realized I am so
much younger than I have ever known
so it's been a year we're about to
embark on the new season of bachelor in
paradise what do you think that the show
needs to do or what do you want to see
them do with this first season since you
know all that happened I think
everything really is like in order like
they change the drinking rules and
things like that I'm excited to see how
it is I think that everyone's gonna have
a really great time and I hope people
find love there will we see you on
Paradise at all I can no not this year
okay okay well I'm really I'm glad to
hear you feel like it seems like you
feel you're just in a much better place
than you were a year I'm proud of myself
and I'm happy and you're with somebody
new tell us about this boyfriend you
guys been going out for a couple months
now and you seem very happy I am his
name is John and how did you meet we met
through friends which is the best way to
be okay and what is it about him that's
got you all he's just like so amazing
he's kind and caring and he's supportive
and he's like confident in his own on
his own and funny on his own I'm just
like he's the pack because he's the
package I feel like you had said this to
me before you know that it's just really
hard to find somebody especially because
you were sort of thrust into the
spotlight so quickly it was hard to find
someone who could handle all that John
knew exactly who I was and like did not
even tell me I like didn't know he knew
anything and like he just kept his cool
and he was like feeling me out the same
way I was feeling him out so normal it
was awesome just good to have a normal
interaction so norm and what does he do
for a living
he does everything he's entrepreneur
he's really smart and he's gonna be a
really big success so I'm and I'm there
to support him the way he's here to
support me okay so you're really really
happy with this guy gasps what level are
we like love we're falling in love we
love each other okay I love him I love
hearing that yeah a lot has happened in
a year yeah and I know you and Damari
are still close as he met Demario
your guy friends does he have a stamp of
approval from family or friends family
approves best friend approves finally
[Laughter]
everyone loves John John's just he's
prince charming he lights up the room
unfortunately like all the ladies love
him I was just a charmer I always laugh
with you about this because you
Instagram did there was like a magazine
cover something where someone an outlet
said that he looked like Nick oh my god
and I don't see no [ __ ] so true so false
so false so we are not here for these
comparisons no and you and Nick I mean
last time Nick was here we did an
interview with him and he you know you
guys kind of go back and forth a little
bit how are you and Nick right now I'm
just not gonna touch on that okay but
what I will touch on is that I did
recently see him and it was cordial at
first it was not and then it was so it's
fine we'll get into that later okay so
it's fine yeah cordial what okay cordial
is the word you I call him Debbie
because he's just so debbie downing all
the time and everyone says it to me and
I'm like I know poor thing
let's help him out guys okay well
cordial is good it's good to be cordial
yes
cordial I'm a lady love it so we have a
new season of bachelor in paradise you
are dating this wonderful guy and I know
that you're so busy with so many
projects I want to talk to about a
little platinum moment you're ready tell
me about it okay well this has been a
huge dream of mine that I actually got
close to doing last year which I had to
sweep under the rug for a little bit
when the scandal happened
my lips are my pride and joy I've had
big lips since I was teeny tiny baby and
I hated them when I was at all and I
would always try to make them look
smaller
I would like underline my lips sometimes
have changed I changed Thank You Carly
Jenner now I love my lips and I love mix
and matching colors and lipsticks and I
always like did my own stuff a lot of
people wanted to know what I was
when I was on The Bachelor does it make
sure a few different things finally I'm
making my own beauty shop amazing and a
lot of platinum beauty shop to come I
don't want to spoil it too much but you
guys are gonna love it there's shades
for everyone and every part of your body
everything it's gonna be great every
part of your body I love that because we
know where the Platinum thing originates
from your signature so and dropping
Friday
nothing Friday jumping up Friday you
guys amazing Congrats
you got so exciting I know um that is
crazy when you were just talking about
like feeling like you lost business
opportunity I did I did I did I did tell
me it like I mean how many you felt like
you lost money and what were people
saying to you that they just didn't want
to they just supposed to be associated
with me and that's so fine but you know
some people did come back because they
realized I'm I didn't do that I didn't I
wasn't in the wrong there no one was in
the wrong it was just something that
needed to be investigated that's it
and a lot of people came back and that's
when I was like no I'm not gonna work
with anyone that doubts me I'm not gonna
be put down as a woman as a human I know
what I am I know where I come from I
know my Worth and I'm not dealing with
anyone that thinks otherwise
all right team corn yes Yas Queen oh I
love that especially because you know
we're in such a great time for women
right now and I think you know this show
has everyone everyone we're in a great
time for everyone to be who you are yes
no matter what that may be well and the
show has such a female audience so and I
was talking to Rachel about that a
little bit like she said being the
bachelor it was very empowering and and
I want to keep seeing the show do that
like empower women and let them have
their moment and make their calls and
decisions awesome
alright so platinum beauty out Friday
thank you so much for being here miss
Corinne you guys thank you as always for
talking to us about the Bachelorette we
are winding down we just have a few more
episodes left Colton did not make it to
fantasy suite oh what an interesting
episode that would have been but we have
Garrett we have Blake we have Jason we
want to know who you think Becca is
going to choose so let us know in a new
episode of rose and Rose they will be up
on our YouTube channel later today and
Korean thank you for being here
thank you for having me all right
I follow her on social media check out
platinum beauty and we'll talk to you
soon bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]